the worst thing that I've ever done
people will remember my successes and
they will also remember those failures
Arnold Schwarzenegger's secret affair
the actor opens up about how he finally
came clean about his love child with the
family housekeeper it was very tough on
my marriage and my relationship with the
kids that have caused enough pain for my
family I'm gonna have to live with it
the rest of my life in his new Netflix
doc Arnold says that in 2011 then wife
Maria Shriver asked him Point Blank
during couples counseling if he was the
father of the housekeeper's boy Joseph
baina Arnold says quote I thought my
heart stopped and then I told the truth
yes Maria Joseph is my son she was
obviously crushed I was just I think too
scared about losing everything losing
her losing the family Arnold's now fully
embraced his role as father to Joseph
his look-alike bodybuilder son I was
supporting each other this important
thing it's great having that father-son
relationship that we've built Arnold
also opens up in the dock about his
Fierce rivalry with Sylvester Stallone
in this corner
I think in the beginning we're a bit
competitive the fittest was survive E.T
watched the action Stars Battle it out
in the 90s I was trying to go out to him
and he was trying to out to me and
whatever we do you know that's just the
way it is in the three-part series
Arnold which premieres June 7th Sly says
we couldn't even stand to be in the same
room then we realized it was good for
our careers because you want someone to
push you you always want to outdo and
this was a shocker I'll be back turns
out Arnold kind of stole the role of the
Terminator away from O.J Simpson Arnold
says imadoc producers were skeptical
that OJ could be sold as a killing
machine to audiences and then Arnold
explained his thoughts on the role to
director James Cameron I said this has
to be done like a machine everything
automatic so I kept talking like that
the whole lunch very enthusiastically
like an expert at the end of the lunch
it says there's no one that would
understand the Terminator better than
you
[Music]